wow it's incredible can you feel it uh
let me just explain yeah that um for the
first time
since
the pandemic began uh we're all in the
same room that's because
matt gurley has joined us in person
you've been uh
at your
beautiful residence in pasadena
um and i mean just gorgeous as from the
background unless it's a fake background
it is okay
but you haven't been here no but now i
feel like the gang's back together yeah
we got the gang back together it feels
good it feels complete it does and i
felt a little alone and vulnerable
without you here yeah so it feels really
nice to have you here as you know
because i think the two of us are
stronger together i agree i liked you
being gone
that's not because i dislike you or
anything but because when son is here by
herself
i can just uh go after her and you
always go come right to her aid yes to
her assistance
but there's that little lag on zoom and
if i'm going after her you know and
sometimes i can just turn your volume
down a bit yeah because you know how to
do that
i'm sorry come on
you control all seven you do the levels
oh okay yeah whatever i know i'm very
technically savvy oh yeah you just go
into a different uh digital modem and
and then take it down a generation
generation i think you did do that
somehow
yeah but anyway um oh my god i uh it's
nice to have you back and it's it is
good to see you matt gurley you know we
joke and we josh and there's a lot of um
you know little snappy snipes going back
and forth but uh you know that you're an
admired member of the team
um you have you have such a hard time
being sincere i know it is like i see
smoke coming out of your future
[Laughter]
why are you wetting your pants right now
you have
certain inalienable rights guaranteed to
through the constitution
and uh and then
so it but therefore you mean a lot too
let me just the person who is me cut you
off and say this is how you do it
i am really glad to be back in fact i
knew i'd be excited to be back but until
i got in this room that's when i really
felt like this feels good i missed you
guys yeah full stop
see that's that's a that's how normal
people act and and i too am so happy to
see you
then and i'm just i feel like everything
is complete and we're good and that's
this is a nice moment conan if i could
just venture to say
that you are a property owner
you're a tax paying citizen
um
you have i'm told you have your merits
how did you get my census data
you uh
you reside on 1.3 acres of land that
uh rests on a uh
shelf of what's predominantly shale
there's shale and then there's some
limestone as well
basically limestone runs runs through
the whole area i'm not happy to be back
this is the best you're gonna get yeah
you're four miles from a fault line you
might want to look into that
so anyway uh good to have you here
it takes so much work i want to have a
christmas card
i mean a greeting card made that says
all those things and then uh
clearly just send it to you just have it
made
just one it just goes on and on and on
this is how much water you displace
when put into a tank it's yeah
35.6 liters of water and then they just
get unrelated this is how much a gallon
of milk costs right now
the day you were born uh the stock
exchange was up
two points oh my god it literally has
been two years since we last were we got
together for that live show but to do an
episode was at my house two years ago
right because the pandemic was just
breaking out march late march yeah it
was late march and um
none of us quite knew what it meant yet
but
they had shut down the studios but we
all met in your backyard which is so
funny like well we can't record the
studios let's just do the same thing in
close proximity in my house right and it
wasn't in the backyard it was in an
enclosed space
yeah and then we uh played the uh face
licking game that's right that was the
comedy that day yeah that was uh uh
followed by
a visit from my new character uncle
sneeze
um
but yeah we did that and then we went
someplace
we all went someplace nearby that was
really cool
was it lunch or dinner it was lunch
lunch it was raining and you had your
crocodile dundee hat on yes yeah i was
wearing it all the time then
and then uh i was sued
by a toothless croc
[Applause]
that was the joke yeah this is you've
made it so much fun yeah yes
yeah
i'm wearing the hat cut to me in court
and uh testifying is a there's a
crocodile
with gums and he's pointing at me that's
a new yorker cartoon right there anyone
want to draw it up yeah i'll split the
money with you 50 50. that's comedy gold
that is called comedy gold right from
the mine right so um
it is good to have you back and i think
this is a sign that we are hitting on
all cylinders now feels like it am i
getting all
sexy jazz yeah sexy welcome to what you
don't find the sexy this is not a jazz
chat oh late night jazz gym oh it could
be though this is awful yeah is it if
you're gonna be why are you doing this
now you didn't do this when you were
virtual well welcome to cohen and the
chill chums that's your sexy voice
that's my sexy jazz voice
that's also your emphysema voice
that's your
my lungs are collapsing because i smoked
for 40 years
could you uh hand me that respirator and
take off your clothes
[Laughter]
people always think you're trying to
come on to them but really
you're just trying to get
no it's good we're here we're stronger
than ever and i think now that we've
been united it's like those uh you're
gonna know the name matt those special
stones that go into the gloves the
shunkrest oh no the infinity stones i
thought you meant i only barely know
those i thought you meant the three
stones from indiana jones and the temple
the doom that light up when they come
together let's go with that no i was
trying to go with something that the
kids would care about come on know that
how about the grandparents the club
what's it called the glove the infinity
gauntlet no the gauntlet is it the
infinity gauntlet he is nodding and if
anybody would know it's blay
is knotting so hard that his throat just
ripped open yeah he's wearing two
infinity gauntlets right now
he's rubbing his chest wearing two
infinity gauntlets that's that's a
friday night with blade
sorry blai but you know you're a big fan
um yeah incredible incredible that's
that's what it's like
whatever that glove was in that marvel
movie that i didn't see
this
this is us we're we've now been
assembled yeah this is us we're more
like the cast of this is us i think oh
that's what you just said this is us no
i haven't seen that either i haven't
either i used to watch it you did
yesterday we are not like the cast of
this is us we're not no not at all what
about if i talk like this oh deep even
further away from it yeah okay no i
think you should go back to zoom yeah i
think so too i think it's great it's
been lovely seeing you yeah
yeah proof that you're alive and i think
you should go back i understand what i
understand is a lovely home in pasadena
yeah that's just a fake background and
i'm in a kind of lean to
uh outside the house yeah you smoked
meats there